hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
so today's video is sponsored by
squarespace and i thought it would be
really fun to do a little responding to
your assumptions slash questions about
me so i went to my community page asked
you for those assumptions and questions
and today we're going to be setting the
record straight but first i want to chat
about my sponsor squarespace because i
know a lot of you are looking to start
some new careers or some new projects
and in 2021 a website is kaneki so if
you're not familiar squarespace it's an
all-in-one platform to build your blog
website online store or just use their
marketing tools and analytics they have
so many awesome new features that are
perfect for new entrepreneurs so you can
connect your site to all of your social
media platforms so it makes it so much
easier to share what you're doing onto
those platforms and they have a lot of
really great blogging tools as well that
i often recommend to a lot of my
blogging friends that i coach i totally
wish that this support was around when i
started my blog because it really would
have saved me so much time and money so
if you're interested in getting started
check out squarespace.com
to get a free trial and when you're
ready to launch your website or domain
check out squarespace.com
abby sharp to get 10 off of your first
purchase of a website or domain we might
have to move around a little bit during
this video just to accommodate the
changing sun right now but i got my
coffee and do you like this new mug
brent rambo
i got this in pei at a little farmer's
market how cute all right let's do it
because i got lots of questions to get
to also don't forget to check out my
disclaimer on screen and in the
description below and if you're new here
definitely hit that subscribe button uh
and make sure you ring the little bell
so you never miss out on an episode why
is the sun so bright in my eyes
[Music]
we're gonna have to move around a lot
during this interview okay i feel like
this is a little bit more flattering in
this moment but it's gonna change
literally question a question so we're
just gonna roll with it first question
first assumption you and your husband
are trying for more kids um
probably not probably not i never say
never but i would say i'm like 99.9
sure
we're done i actually did ivf for those
who don't know i did ivf for both my
children and i have about eight i think
i have eight
more
m babies as we call them in the freezer
so if i want to have more kids
i could potentially try
try
but trying for us is not exactly as
simple as just like crying nice try you
know what i'm saying like it requires a
hell of a lot of needles a lot of
appointments a lot of time a lot of
procedures a hell of a lot of
supplements a lot of crying a lot of
money a lot of just like physical and
emotional
stress yeah there are a few steps
involved and i don't know right now for
me i just feel like
poppy
but i just feel like i'm at a point
right now where i'm so content
with my little family like i can't
actually i try to imagine all the time
as soon as like oh was born i was like
instantly like okay do i want another do
i think do i feel like my family's
complete and every month every few weeks
i reevaluate in my head and i try to
imagine more children and i can't like
now i just feel like my family is
perfect the way it is
but you know i might change my mind i
might not question number two i admire
you for not showing your kids will we
ever meet your hubby
again never say never but
no
there's a greater chance that you'll
meet my kids then you'll meet my hubby
because my husband is very very private
the reason why i don't show my kids for
those who don't know is that i just feel
like
they're too young to consent to wanting
to be part of this
crazy circus that i've created for
myself as a career they need to have a
choice in this matter and right now they
they really can't tell me either way
whether or not they want to be youtubers
my husband can tell me he's an adult
[Music]
does now on be a youtuber in the social
media space he doesn't even have any
social media not even facebook so
i would say
you're not going to meet hubby any time
soon you might see the back of him but
even that's a bit of a stretch maybe
you'll see the back of him he exists i
promise but you probably won't see like
a one-on-one interview with him anytime
soon on my channel okay you've never
been someone to over indulge in fast
food cake biscuits etc and you've always
kept those foods to a minimum so i'd say
i don't over indulge often because i try
to just eat what feels good to my body
and eat amounts of food that feel good
to my body but i'm human so of course
there are definitely days when selling
tastes so good that
i eat past the point of fullness past
the point of what feels good and
comfortable but what really helps me to
mitigate that is that i allow myself
things and foods that i enjoy sweet
foods even fast food whatever and that's
why i don't feel the need to over over
indulge
when i do have those things because i
have them regularly enough that they're
not such a novelty to me you have never
been overweight your struggles with food
have been more of the anorexic
orthorexic end of the spectrum which
isn't to say that you have never felt
fat or tried to slash wanted to lose
weight so yes i
have said this before i have never lived
in a larger body so while i can have a
lot of empathy and i can acknowledge how
unaccepting and cruel the world is to
larger bodied folks i have no direct
experience with this myself having said
that i don't think any of us are immune
to the pressures to want to be thin this
we live in a fat phobic society where
fitness is of course
given a lot of privilege so while my
eating disorder orthorexia the one that
i was suffering from
throughout most of my kind of late teen
years early early 20s was more about
kind of an obsession with wellness or
being healthy rather than with
restricting to for the sake of weight
reduction i can say with absolute
certainty that of course there will
always be and have always been days
where i feel insecure about my body even
today even with all of the work that
i've done okay next question there is a
lot of construction going on
oh no oh no
oh yeah
and that is what living in the city is
like conflict between you and other
youtube hosts stresses you out in spite
of yourself because you're used to
having civil seminar table discussions
like a grad student
wow you guys think i'm so cool don't you
all the family all the family meals are
just like everyone sit down
you know take your turn let's have a
civil debate honestly being a type a
people pleaser perfectionist i would be
lying if i said that i love the drama i
actually hate the drama i hate conflict
however i take full responsibility for
any conflict that arises and i see it as
something that you know it just comes
with the territory and something that i
just have to accept in order for me to
sometimes take down a lot of the harmful
misinformation there is out there but
this is why i started the fed up series
so if you haven't watched some of those
interviews yet definitely check it out i
really wanted to have you know
respectful civilized professional
conversations with other content
creators even if we're very different or
if we disagree on a lot of things
okay next question i assume you've gone
to therapy and done the work you give me
healing vibes yes
years
and years
of therapy
i spent a lot of time and a lot of money
but a lot of time
like analyzing my thoughts doing the
work as you said and i've done quite a
few different i don't know modalities
cbt cbti which is cbt for
insomnia dbt mindfulness based therapy
hypnotherapy
emdr psychoanalytic work i don't
remember what all of them are called i'm
not a psychologist this is outside my
scope but my sister's actually a
psychologist so she's definitely helped
me to navigate this space based on my
own symptoms and what she feels is going
to be most helpful for me but i know
that just based on maturity and my you
know all of the work that i have done
i've definitely come a really long way
since my days as you know a child and
also a teenager and a young adult okay
next question
you're very type a person and you
definitely wear the pants in your
relationship definitely type a yes you
were right about that but but i think
that my husband and i actually have
quite a good balance in terms of who
defers to who for different things
so there are some things that he is more
passionate about or more opinionated
about and vice versa so we have a good
sense of like who's responsible for
wearing the pants on different aspects
of home life
so we actually used this book called
fair play this is the playing cards you
have to buy them separately from the
book i recommend both but anyways the
idea is that there's all these playing
cards that
represent different household chores so
you and your partner can divvy them up
so to speak
and be responsible for that chore or
that uh deliverable from start to finish
conceptualization planning and execution
so for example
um it could be something like
planning
school breaks so
who's going to do that i'm going to do
that because i'm a planner obviously
remember that time we went to the deli
for cold cuts and the ticket machine was
broken so you found out what time
everyone arrived and made them getting a
single file line from earliest to latest
yeah he's gonna deal with all the tech
stuff stuff related to the car
separately to the dog those are
typically his domain i mean there's
other ones obviously too we we really
tried to make it as fair as possible
even though
ultimately i end up taking on two thirds
of the pack
but still at least i feel like the cards
that he holds
i don't have to think about so it really
has reduced the mental load and the
mental burden for me anyways okay next
question you sometimes feel insecure
about the content you put onto youtube
you know i actually feel pretty
confident about what i put out there um
i really think it's important that us
content creators feel a sense of
responsibility for our work um so i am
also you know very forthcoming if
there's something i'm not sure about
and if i'm wrong about something or if
new information
comes up
and i'm corrected i am always happy to
put that updated information in a
description or a pinned comment etc i do
try to be as you know transparent about
that as possible because ultimately i am
human
and
and things are always changing as well
in the nutrition world okay next
question i assume you avoid calling out
nutrition bs with your extended family
members but still probably it makes you
heated i actually call it nutrition bs
with my family all the time it's one of
my favorite pastimes it can be awkward i
will say and sometimes i get a little
bit ragey
and the times when i don't give like a
full on ted talk of course
i go home and then like you know i get
on google scholar and i like pull up all
these resources and factoids and stats
and and then i of course ruminate over
it all night long and like oh i should
have said x y and z and and i like come
up with all these great responses that i
can bust out next time anyone else do
that i do that yeah leave me a comment
below if that is your life pattern
because that is just like a typical type
a personality trait but it's definitely
one of the reasons it keeps me up at
night but yes to answer your question i
have a very hard time holding back when
it comes to a lot of nutrition bs
especially with people that i actually
care about because i definitely don't
want them to be like you know buying
into the snake oil next question i
assume that you became a dietitian
because of your own struggles with food
you wanted to educate yourself and help
others too yeah absolutely and
you know i found out what a dietitian
was because i had seen a dietitian when
i was struggling with my eating disorder
otherwise i probably wouldn't even know
anything about that job but i will say
that eating disorders are rampant in the
dietetic student community i've got a
blog post on this there's research on
this and it really does make sense
because i think a lot of people who are
kind of
really obsessed with food and and really
interested in food for various reasons
go into dietetics because it's like hey
why wouldn't i want to make a job out of
this if i'm already thinking about
nutrition and food and calories and
numbers and all of those things all day
anyways but when i graduated and i did
my internship and all that stuff you
know i was i was still in recovery and i
found the industry to be just too
triggering for me so i actually went to
grad school at that point for sociology
i was wanting to research kind of
gendered
food choices and eating behaviors and
during that time i also started my food
blog and my food blog actually became
really the jumping off point to my
recovery like you know we talk about
going all in and that's kind of
essentially what i did even though i
didn't call it that at the time but i
had to jump in there throw caution into
the wind i was going to all these food
events and restaurant openings and
eating out multiple times in the week
and i really couldn't do that if i was
going to be stuck in my eating disorder
all right this is a question did you
ever offend any of the subjects in your
what i need day reviews and did they
contact you about it i think the wedding
day videos are very personal and i
imagine a few feathers have been ruffled
yeah i have had a couple handful of
content creators reach out to me over
the years lemon water sometimes
they're defensive but for the most part
they're
they've been quite
even if i'm not like 100 complimentary
and there's been some critique there for
the most part i think that they've been
quite professional and um kind of
appreciative of my commentary you know a
lot of these content creators are not
dietitians obviously none of them are so
i think that there is a little bit of
kind of respectful dialogue there and
that's kind of a nice thing about this
um about this industry and community but
of course it does weigh on me more than
i probably should i am a people pleaser
as i already mentioned taipei
personality and sometimes i do feel bad
and guilty but ultimately like i always
say i think that as content creators we
have a responsibility for the content
that we put out there and i feel that i
have a professional responsibility to
correct some of the kind of nutrition
misinformation there is out there
through my professional lens i assume
you think pumpkin spice is overrated you
use facebook think the name august is
nice and you like the color forest green
somebody definitely
gets me somebody knows my soul i don't
mind pumpkin spice but i don't love it i
would way rather have like a caramel
flavor
coffee if that's what i was feeling like
something sweet but i really don't like
any of those kind of sweet uh flavored
lattes just give me it straight up if i
want dessert i'm gonna have a slice of
cake right it's just too closingly sweet
for me i always feel like the first sip
is kind of like oh that's something new
that's something nice but then after
that i'm just like why am i drinking
this this is torture yes i love facebook
facebook to me is like the only low
stress
social media platform because i yes i
use it for my business but i mainly just
use it to connect with friends and
family and to look at my friends and
family photos of their kids and their
dogs also funny enough i love the name
august it was actually on my short list
maybe it was like the long list it was
like the long list for oh because he was
actually an august baby and i like the
name i think it's cool what was the
other thing i love a good forest green
got some greenery in the back i've got
green eyes so green looks nice on me
okay had to switch you because i was
getting overwhelmed with the sunlight
now i just look
like an angel with my
blonde hair you're like an angel with no
wings
so like a person
next question speaking of angels
you love christmas and you always stock
up on a ton of decorations and gifts
yes
i love christmas i'm obsessed with
christmas just reading the word
christmas it's like
i can taste
the candy canes in my mouth and i am
here for it i'm jewish but we still
celebrate christmas because my family
they're not christian but they celebrate
christmas and we celebrate
in a big way because growing up we never
like got a lot of toys throughout the
year so it was like christmas was the
day for my parents to go a little bit
crazy and basically stock up on anything
that we might need for the year ahead
and that's what they would do so we have
a big blowout christmas and now that
i've got kids myself my parents are like
back to
going
crazy on buying gifts for them and
honestly i i always tell them like don't
buy them anything they don't need
anything
but it brings e so much joy to open up
those gifts he doesn't really care
what's inside them so much so he just
like wants to rip into that paper
and i'm sure this will be oh's second
christmas but last year he was literally
just like a blob so this year he'll be a
little bit more into the festivities i'm
excited about them you excited and i'm
so excited if you guys are excited and
want to see some christmas content let
me know because i am i'm i'm ready for
it all right next question
you were the kid in the class that would
sit in the first line and always
answered when the teacher made a
question
about the lecture yep
any of my classmates know i was the girl
in the front front row and my hand
always up the teacher is probably just
like ugh yes abby
mr potter and i still am i just like to
say the answer out loud because i think
it helped me remember it as well or
maybe i just liked the attention either
way type a perfectionist that's me all
right next
do you think that for yourself and or
for others you use your ed history as an
excuse to not go vegan or more
plant-based this is a sincere question
not an accusation by the way so
no i do not think that this is an excuse
at all i feel that i've gone as
plant-based as i can comfortably without
me falling into scarcity mentality
because i think that if i were to make
very specific rules about not eating
any dairy or not eating any meat any
fish ever again that i'd find myself in
the scarcity mentality and what i would
do is i would rebel so in the end i
probably would find myself eating
less plant-based as a result of being so
strict and restrictive about it so i
just feel like i know my mind and body
really well and what's physically and
emotionally healthy for myself and i
also think because of my ibs that i
would have a really hard time physically
going fully plant-based it would just
not feel good to me or i would just have
so few options based on my kind of ibs
triggers that i probably wouldn't be
able to meet my kind of micronutrient
needs so this is a personal choice and
one that everyone has to make and i
think that just by choosing more
plant-based foods that i'm doing the
best that i can and i am getting so
effing hot
all right we're gonna do a full circle
on this table just gonna cover all of
our angles here okay
next question you're terrified that no
matter how much you try to avoid it your
kids are going to be affected negatively
by diet culture when they get older yeah
they will this is like part of the
reason why i was like somewhat relieved
to have
two boys even though i'm well aware that
even boys are not immune to the pressure
to want to be thin or
wellness culture etc
but i do think that still with you know
social media especially
things are still a little bit harder for
girls that's just my opinion but of
course like i said there's always going
to be outliers but statistically that
just that's that's where we're at right
now but ultimately i can't protect them
from that world it's going to be
inevitable they already know how to use
a cell phone i mean the other day
i was at starbucks with e on the weekend
we usually go for starbucks and we get
like chocolate croissants or like
whatever they want and i asked e if he
wanted a
croissant and normally he wants a
chocolate croissant he's like chocolate
did you say chocolate but this day he
said plain please i don't want the
chocolate he said the chocolate's too
high in sugar and my husband and i both
looked at each other like where the did
he hear that from and i was really quick
to say to him you know sugar's okay
sugar gives us energy if we eat a lot of
sugar it may upset our tummy but there's
nothing wrong with sugar but i'm glad
that you're listening to what your body
says and choosing what feels best to you
and that's kind of how i left it i
bought him the regular croissant because
that's what he asked for so i just try
not to make a big deal like what i
didn't want to do is be like oh good
choice good choice like you know go for
the low sugar option go for the diet
option low carb keto life peace so yeah
i really try to keep things neutral but
like i said like
he clearly heard that somewhere and it
wasn't coming from me and he's going to
hear those kinds of sentiments
everywhere all his life no matter where
he looks and all i can do is try to
neutralize them at home i'm wondering
about your favorite ways to handle the
internet pressure food and nutrition
information is such a contested space
and you always seem to rise above the
drama
how do you remain focused that's a
really good question because honestly i
don't even i don't think that i am
really great at that i actually find
this world uh and this job and community
is particularly very hard it's very
taxing but i'm glad that i play the part
well but i just remind myself that my
goal is to help the public make more
informed decisions about
where and from whom they
get their nutrition information from and
if people are going to troll me over
something that they disagree with me on
and lose or shut me
that's not a me problem that's a them
problem like if they have time to write
a two-page hate letter to me to try to
justify their choices to me
they're probably trying to justify their
choice to themselves
that's how i think of it and a little
fun question here would you share an
unpopular opinion about a popular food
so for example my ex-roommate hates
scrambled eggs and mashed potatoes
because they taste boring to her also my
husband doesn't like coconut shreds or
carrot shreds because the texture makes
him think of fingernail clippings
do you have something like that i can
see that being a thing for coconut
shreds i haven't thought of it being
like fingernail clippings before so now
that's a real great visual for
tomorrow's breakfast you ruined it for
me it's mayo so here's the funny thing
about mayo if it's on like a burger like
if i'm ordering a sandwich in a
restaurant and they put mayo on the
burger or even if it's like a fancy
aioli that a restaurant has whipped up
i'm for it i love the taste of mayo
title your sex tape love love love it
especially on something like a sandwich
or a burger because i like that tangy
zip but i cannot and will not
put a knife or a spoon into a jar of
mayo
and
spread it onto a sandwich myself i
cannot
deal with the gloopy like
that's what it sounds like i can't
handle that sound it really
it just turns me right the f off i don't
know if anyone else feels the same way
let me know in the comments below would
love to hear i'm not the only psychopath
out there but on that note that is all
that i got for you today leave me a
comment below on other assumptions or
questions that you have and maybe i'll
answer them in a upcoming video and also
make sure that you're subscribed so that
you can see any of these upcoming posts
and polls and questions that i asked in
my community page um and of course a big
thank you again to squarespace for
sponsoring if you liked it give me that
thumbs up and i will see you next time
on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]